et pour en parler avec mon direct rocco
contento roux secrétaire départemental
paris unité sgp police monsieur concept
de bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors hier castaner
aujourd'hui gérald darmanin j'ai envie
de vous demander est-ce que c'est mieux
selon vous m'écoutez il est trop tôt
pour le dire on jugera sur pièces
gérald ammann a été l'ancien ministre du
budget et des comptes publics
donc en ce qui nous concerne c'était
surtout le ministre du gel du point
d'indicé dans la fonction publique qui
n'a pas évolué durant des années
à partir de là je dirai aux ministres
qu'il n'aura pas d'état de grâce
ce n'est pas parce que monsieur castanet
répartis comme suit darmana arrive avec
quelques paroles rassurantes que la
polaire policière va s'apaiser
nous jugerons sur pièce il ya des grands
dossiers d'ordre généraux qui sont sur
la table depuis des mois voire des
années
en ce qui concerne la police nationale
et comme monsieur darmana connais
parfaitement toutes les ficelles de
bercy j'espère qu'il pourra débloquer
des crédits pour que ces réformes enfin
voit le jour nous demandons une somme
très pragmatique et du tgp pauliste
mendois secoue nouveau au soir très
rapidement et nous voulons au delà des
paroles des actes forts pour l'instant
on attend pour l'instant est bien de
prendre cette fonction et on jugera
selon les actes c'est vrai difficile de
juger alors qu'il n'a encore rien fait
justement concrètement qu'est ce que
vous attendez de la part du nouveau
ministre de l'intérieur alors déjà
plusieurs choses la première chose il a
déclaré qu'il soutiendrait sa police et
qui la protégerait donc ça passe par le
fait que lorsque l'institution sera
diffamé il déposera plainte aussi ce que
malheureusement ça n'a pas été toujours
le cas précédemment j'en réfère à la
fière camélia jordana ou cette chanteuse
avait diffamé la police en disant que la
police pas sacré le ministre de l'époque
n'avait pas déposé plainte
nous en tant qu'organisations syndicales
nous l'avons fait donc un soutien pour
sa police et surtout que les chantiers
qui sont sur la table
alors excusez moi je vais parler d'un
peu de catégorielles mais les voix
d'avancement dans la police nationale le
statut du travailleur de nuit le
la réforme de l'opg tout ça doit voir le
jour et de grandes réformes
nous souhaitons une grande loi
d'orientation de programmation de
sécurité intérieure pour faire en sorte
que le métier soit tiré vers le haut que
ce soit au niveau du matériel je vous
rappelle un exemple que dans sur le
territoire national nous avons dix mille
véhicules en voie de réforme
donc là dessus il faut investir sur
matériel neuf
les investissements matériels
malheureusement ont décliné depuis plus
d'un an
donc voilà il a fort à faire et je vous
le répète il n'aura pas d'état de grâce
de la part des policiers de nationaux
parvenir rapidement à castet maire qui
était lié au ministère de l'intérieur
est ce que vous êtes au moins satisfait
qu'il ait eu un changement à ce
ministère est ce que c'est ce que vous
attendiez un changement écoutez je
dirais que peu importe le casting mais
il est vrai que monsieur castaner il y
avait un lien de confiance qui avaient
été rompues avec les policiers nationaux
depuis si récente une déclaration sa
conférence de presse notamment lorsqu'il
avait parlé de suspicion de racisme dans
la police nationale
ce qui était complètement annonçant ce
juridique sas avait mis le feu aux
poudres
écoutez nous verrons nous jugerons sur
pièce avec le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur alors et pour parler aussi
du premier ministre un jean castex
on l'a vu les partis visiter un
commissaire hier au lendement quelques
jours après sa nomination c'est là un
acte fort qu'est ce que ça veut dire
selon vous m'écoutez c'est déjà un très
bon signal lorsqu'un ministre de
l'intérieur prend ses fonctions il a le
choix soit de visiter une gendarmerie
niçois un commissaire de police
il est mieux que mais ça de la courneuve
qui est un commissariat très difficile
sur le département le plus criminogène
le seine-saint-denis est lui aussi des
paroles assez forte
maintenant ce que nous attendons c'est
que les paroles du premier ministre se
concrétise en actes jean castex jean
castex monsieur contact ot merci d'avoir
et en direct avec nous sur rt frange
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental par et unité sgp police
merci